[Music]
well good evening this is morgan on the
sense of breaking news in the last few
minutes gilain maxwell the former
girlfriend of billionaire pedophile
jeffrey epstein has been sentenced to 20
years in a u.s prison for helping
epstein abused four teenage girls
incredibly just before the sentencing
was announced maxwell stood up in court
and played the victim herself she said i
empathize deeply with all the victims in
this case i acknowledged that i had been
a victim of helping jeffrey epstein
commit these crimes an extraordinary
thing to say well just before the
sentencing damning impact statements
were read out including from virginia du
frey who's become one of the most
well-known accusers of jeffrey epstein
after settling a sexual assault case
against prince andrew the duke of york
who denies her claims in her statement
duffray accused gilean maxwell of
opening the door to hell
another victim sarah ransom broke down
in tears and said she became against her
will nothing more than a human sex toy
with a heartbeat and soul for the
entertainment of ebstein maxwell and
others was subjected to sexual predation
multiple times per day she spoke out on
her way into court
i spent the last 17 years in my own
prison
for what she
took three
and all the golden spirits did to me i
was raped
three times a day sometimes
and i was not here
well joining me now live from the
courthouse in lower manhattan new york
is julia janae from court tv julia uh a
20-year sentence for gilead maxwell uh
already some victims coming out saying
this is way too lenient it could have
been a lot more but the judge gave an
indication before passing sentence that
was going to be in that 15 to 20 range
what is your reaction to this
no piers we did know what the federal
sentencing guidelines were going to be
because the judge decided that before a
short break she believed it was going to
be around 17 to 21 but putting it into
perspective these prosecutors were
asking for 30 years 255 years so to hear
that this number is 20 years you can
understand how those survivors would
react to hearing it being so low
compared to what prosecutors were asking
for but when you look at the guidelines
it does fall within that range around
the max of what she could have received
under those federal sentencing
guidelines but the judge said herself
she is not bound by those guidelines and
she would have been able to enhance this
beyond had she felt that this was
warranted but she did say that she
believed that this is something that is
not too great of a punishment to go
beyond what is necessary but she said
that it is sufficient to punish her for
these heinous acts and the pattern
behavior that she found so objectionable
julia thank you very much dude we're
gonna go live now to bobby sternheim who
is the attorney actually for gillane
maxwell who's talking outside court
right now
and the issues on appeal
[Music]
kevin you're speaking yes what she said
in a moment uh just wrapping up there
with the reporters outside the court but
what we can tell you this is what gilley
maxwell said in court before the
sentencing was announced i think it's
pretty extraordinary what she said here
she got up and she said your honor it's
hard for me to address the court of
listening to the pain and anguish
expressed today the terrible impact on
the lives of so many women is difficult
to hear and even more difficult to
absorb on its scale and its extent i
want to acknowledge their suffering i
empathize deeply with all the victims in
this case i acknowledge with that i have
been a victim of helping jeffrey epstein
commit those crimes
his impact upon all those who are close
to has been devastating jeffrey epstein
fooled all of those in his orbit victims
considered him to be a godfather a
mentor a benefactor a friend a lover
it's absolutely unfathomable today to
think that was how he was viewed
contemporaneously i'm sorry for the pain
that you have experienced i hope this
brings the women who suffered some
measure of peace and faintly to help you
put those experiences so many years ago
in a place that allows you to look
forward and not back it's my sincerest
wish to all those of miss courtroom and
all those outside this courtroom that
today brings a terrible chapter to an
end may this day help you travel through
darkness into the light well i'm joined
now
this is the laura laura again bobby's
done let's see we can pick this up you
deserve to uncover it thank you so much
okay well so
i want to go now to the criminal defense
attorney mark garagos and tom bowers
with me he's a best-selling uh
biographer of gillane's father robert
maxwell the newspaper publisher media
magnet let me start with you tom an
extraordinary statement before the
sentence was announced by gilley maxwell
really putting herself as if she was
another victim nothing to do with me gov
i'm with you in fact this line here i
acknowledge that i have been a victim of
helping jeffrey epstein commit those
crimes how can accomplice be a victim
well it's not only that but why didn't
you say that before the sentence before
the verdict why didn't she say in her in
defense what was remarkable about the
trial is that she promised the world she
was going to demolish the prosecution
and prove her innocence and when the
case came for the defense it just
collapsed and this just shows she was
seeking mitigation but it's all a phony
it's all rubbish she knows very well
what she did and she was guilty you have
no doubt about that absolutely none at
all i think that the evidence was
overwhelming and i think that uh the
only thing she didn't bring into that
statement was blaming her father right
and i think rightly so because i really
think that bob maxwell as you all know
was an unbelievable bully thief and a
dreadful man in many ways the one thing
he wasn't was a sexual pervert and
bizarrely we still don't know why
guillain was that uh accomplished of
that perversion and we know that she's
guilty very guilty mark garagos i mean i
suppose one of the reasons she might be
continuing to profess her innocence and
play the victim is she is appealing i
guess if she made any admissions at this
stage that would obviously wreck her
appeal will that be the thinking here
yes and that's exactly what i was going
to say you stepped right on it the uh
she's going to appeal contrary to what
your other guest says she's got a very
solid grounds for appeal i mean remember
it may have been forgotten but one of
the jurors brought in his own personal
experiences and uh said that he that his
experiences are what tipped the balance
during jury deliberations in the favor
of guilt that's that's clearly um
something that would be prejudicial the
judge overruled those objections and
denied the motion for a new trial but
that she's got a very good and live
appeal even though appeals are always a
long shot in the federal system um there
would make it makes no sense for her
because by the way a 20-year sentence in
federal court in america you're going to
do
a lot of that time if not 18 years or
something along those lines that's a
substantial sentence and well within the
guidelines um as was indicated by your
previous guest and she's got a viable
appeal so that's clearly the explanation
for why she made the statement that way
can we read anything mark into the fact
that she got the lower end of the
spectrum of centers it could have been
up to 55 60 years but the judge made a
point of saying it was going to be in a
much lower range
can we read anything into that does that
indicate that the judge may herself have
thought that was perhaps some doubt here
well remember once again when it came
for that motion for new trial this judge
specifically and she's going to a higher
court this was her last uh trial in the
district court she specifically ordered
the hearing here the uh the doj the
prosecutors were the ones who brought it
to her attention immediately and asked
for a hearing
there's a lot going on here and clearly
if she had gone
way above the guidelines that would have
gotten the attention of the appellate
court as well even though that's not
supposed to be the case so i think
there's uh there's quite a bit going on
here i would not be so sure that this
case does not get overturned i think
there's a
sufficient grounds
to make a very credible appeal here okay
well different views from our two
panelists here let me ask you tom just
on a wider issue it obviously wasn't
just epstein and gillam maxwell
committing crimes here we know that they
had a long client list of rich powerful
apparently some famous people on that
list
we don't know who they are are we going
to find out well i think we do know who
they are i mean we there'd be lots of
gossip and we won't mention the names
here but the point about it is that in
the essence and this is where i disagree
with your previous guest
that
gilead maxwell undoubtedly for many many
years was looking for girls
to groom and to provide for epstein and
i believe those girls not because i
believe victims per se but because their
evidence was irrefutable and there are
too many of them exactly far too many i
think about the sentence there's a life
sentence for her she's 60 right she'll
be 80 i mean you that's near to death so
i think that's why it's 20 years but i
think what's really important here is
that epstein did as you rightly say have
this huge circle of very very
influential friends many of whom who saw
what was happening and didn't raise the
alarm they must be utterly terrified
that guillain will finally do the dirt
why not why hasn't she so far because i
think she would be that would be
self-incriminating she doesn't want to
say that she was but couldn't she have
done it i mean let me bring in mark
garagos again could she not mark have
done a deal i've seen that many times in
these kind of cases in america if she
said look i'll give you the names of all
these rich powerful people who were
involved in this but i want a much
reduced sentence would she have would
she have got that she played that card
if that look the federal criminal system
is predicated on the idea that you get
that they indict somebody or they
threaten to indict somebody and that the
person then cooperates and gives you
more or says that they're going to give
you more regarding somebody else usually
going up the
ladder so to speak so yes that was
clearly something she could have done in
her defense i think that she feels like
and her lawyers have argued this all
along that she was being prosecuted by
proxy that in fact that because they
didn't have epstein that a number of
these things changed and they made a
pretty good case for that during the
trial itself they showed that a number
of these witnesses did not say
originally when epstein was alive that
she was the kind of prime mover of this
that they only changed or came to that
recollection after he died so i think
maybe going into it she had and you know
i don't have any extraordinary insight
into what she was doing but it would not
surprise me that she thought she had a
completely or at least an arguably
defensible case
that there was clearly some doubt in
that jury deliberation room because the
person who says that he was molested
says that he his own words gave an
interview and said i convinced those who
were on the fence that this this kind of
discrepancies that you see in the
testimony is something that's standard
operating procedure when you're
victimized
margaret thank you very much as always
for your astute analysis of that we
appreciate you joining us it's like a
short break tom you stay with me i'm
going to be joined also by lady victoria
harvey next who was a close friend of
gillane maxwell breaking news tonight
socialite gillam maxwell's been
sentenced to 20 years in jail for child
sex trafficking but joining me now daddy
victoria harvey who is in the same
social circles as gilead maxwell and
robert maxwell's biographer tom bower is
still with me well thank you for uh
racing in to talk about this i mean you
knew gillane maxwell for a long time you
socialized with her uh what do you make
of this is i mean apart from anything
else it's an astonishing fall from grace
but what do you think of the center it
is i think the sentencing is
fairly predictable i mean this is what
her lawyers did ask for they asked for
20 years
which is more lenient that what was
being requested
but um i think she will be obviously not
happy but she's probably happy that it's
not more than 20. and i think for good
behavior and things like that the fact
that she's already been in there for a
couple years that all come into play and
i think it should end up being
it'll be unlocked do you have any
sympathy for her
um
i think
you know knowing what i do
um
a little bit but not so much i mean the
theory
well what she wants us all to believe
notwithstanding the conviction and
everything else she wants us to believe
that epstein was the monster that he had
winked and conned everybody she put it
she conned godfather's mentors
benefactors friends lovers she was
reportedly a lover well the fact is you
know
he died and she's taken the wrath of it
and the fact that it doesn't mean she
doesn't deserve to no it doesn't mean
that but it means that the whole focus
has always been on galen because there's
no epstein to blame so all the girls
everyone the blame has just completely
gone to her and i think that is unfair
in a way obviously she deserves you know
to to be in jail but the fact that
there's no one else to take the blame if
she did that she'd do what she did she
will be dead as well like i i give it
six months she'll have a hit on her in
the jail well certainly after what
happened to epstein just like epstein
well they'll be very careful i'm sure
not that it happened
tom you know you've studied the max
wells for so long it's an
extraordinary dramatic roller coaster
ride this family one of her brothers
came out only last week with a very sort
of painful interview as you'd expect
from her brother i guess um there's a
pleading for mercy for and insisting his
sister is innocent
is it possible that she was like
everybody else apparently was with
epstein conned by this guy absolutely
not she's a product of bail college
she's a highly intelligent woman
she knew exactly what she was doing all
the people i've spoken to who were
picked up by her were seduced by her in
parks jumping out of cars asking them to
come for years on end she was working
for epstein and i think the relationship
was unbelievably sordid and criminal and
i think ian who got away himself uh was
found not guilty of fraud
in a trial which i thought would go the
other way but he was found innocent by
thought that um
gillane should have the same uh
treatment that maxwell's never get
convicted but you know the whole point
about gillane is her defense was
absolutely useless she put up no defense
whatsoever having promised the public
that she was going to defend herself and
most important of all didn't go into the
witness box
that was the most self-incriminating
part yeah
and whenever people don't do that there
is always a feeling well that they must
not want to risk
themselves right right yeah the prince
andrew aspect of this
so he has come to this settlement with
one of these victims virginia dufrese to
the tune of what will come to you in
america the guy
a multi-million dollar lawsuit reported
up to up to 11 million dollars
having said even clear his name and
fighting court he then caved and gave
her a check where does he know he's
trying to make a comeback in public life
that nobody's got much appetite for how
damaging is this conviction do you think
that his chances have ever returned oh i
think hugely damaging i think andrew is
finished i think the public is sick to
death of him and i'm afraid his brother
his brother um will be her problems too
i think with all the taking millions of
euros in cash so i think that the royal
family really needs to bury andrew uh
the photograph is absolutely genuine
well that's a photograph i mean that
photo is fake well before you just say
you know you know you always worry about
it
you say it's fake look at the picture in
front of me look if you say this but you
don't know that i know because i'm in
touch with the person that took those
pictures and it's not andrew in the
picture it's epstein i thought uh the
one you've seen the real picture well if
that picture's fake why didn't he go to
court and clear his name because i found
the guy that took the pictures after
he'd done the settlement what's his name
i'm not telling you no one knows this
yet i see
are you
sorry
no no sorry i'm not going to apologize
for the language sorry but i am in touch
with the person that took the photo and
interestingly enough she did meet him in
a park you said about her picking up
people in a park but he is uh why did
prince andrew give her 11 million
dollars if he's a completely innocent
man the inner the the proof that i had i
was in the middle of digging it all up
and the evidence i had when someone came
came to me which i to be honest i
thought this guy was nuts when he first
sent me a picture of this famous picture
that we're so used to seeing but it had
epstein's head in it i looked at it and
i thought
people can muck around with pictures
david with exactly how the story went
down and i've had police visit this guy
and i've had so again why would andrew
then if that picture he'd already paid
her he paid her andrew wasn't even able
to really deny that picture was no real
why didn't you why didn't you because
that was
in that house you've been on that floor
guys glenn photoshopped it she's the one
that followed why didn't andrew fight
his case why give why give the woman
he'd already 11 million dollars
he'd settled as i was unraveling it i
didn't have the guy that took the
pictures when he settled
this happened like a few weeks
afterwards right
the reality is that
andrew played this check uh having said
he clear his name i agree with you i
think it's very hard to see a way back
particularly given that he hasn't even
tried to make any sort of atonement for
it right
now the real story will
the public has any appetite for andrew's
atonement i think the royal family has
so many problems now the last thing they
need
is a resurrection of andrew and the most
important thing now i think is for uh
andrew disappear elaine to disappear and
this story uh finally reaches another
well no because there's so much more to
unravel well we'll see we'll see we'll
see if it unravels you you socialize
with epstein and gillane right
dinner parties with them yeah so what
was the deal with these dinner parties
what do you mean what was the deal with
these who was there what were they doing
what was that it's a normal situation
that you would see like in santa pay you
know wealthy men with young girls right
um
his crowd you know who you would see i
don't know there's a few live pictures
here there's two of guillain maxwell's
sisters outside the courtroom we'll go
to them if they do speak to the media
waiting there yeah i remember like you
say a normal thing i mean
models
they were trafficking young girls for
abuse and then these traffickers became
traffickers didn't they like virginia
well all they became well these are
allegations that have not been
substantiated
she's admitted it on television right as
being a recruiter you have to be very
careful about what you say about people
who have not been convicted of crimes
right this is we're not in a court of
public opinion right here when we are
but
television you say it was like a sort of
sanctuary dinner party but the truth is
it was unbelievably malevolent what was
going on elaine maxwell was sourcing
these young sometimes underrated she was
basically for the delectation of this
paedophile billionaire jeffrey epstein
i'm just curious peter and his i met her
for five minutes at a book launch
i never i never met absolutely she was
perfectly charming to me as you as you
expect from everyone who's met her as
told i didn't know anything about this
side of her life obviously i never met
epstein but i am curious what was the
whole this guy had on so many rich
famous powerful people well it was
blackmail so he enticed them in
and he got blackmail on all of them so
she would record she would do her own
recording so they would have a situation
get these girls get them in political
characters in situations with girls
epstein would record it and galen would
tell the survivor girls i'm in touch
with she would get her own insurance she
called it insurance and they would have
the peep holes of hotels there was a
hotel in canada
epstein was operating in canada before
the us but if you were there if you were
one of the girls at these parties did
you ever get introduced into joining in
any of the activity or not i mean not
that i can remember no i mean i don't i
mean i didn't sleep with any of his
friends right um was i there to entice
them in probably you know i had a title
and it was probably respectable having
somebody like me there where the other
girls wouldn't feel so nervous so think
oh this girl lady victoria okay she's
there so i'm not going to be scared
being around these people what do you
feel now that now that we know the truth
about epstein yeah gilley and maxwell to
one side for a moment but now we know
what he was like that he was this
disgusting depraved predatory pedophile
yeah he's like a serial killer what do
you feel about that well well i i
watched all his depositions that he did
the recorded ones and those are really
freaky it really brings out his
character there's this one video where
he
completely says i have no recollection
of virginia and he makes the guy spell
out virginia as in all the letters and
says what is that and the guy has to
spell out vi art
you know what i mean complete psychopath
tom it's you know it's a horrible
heinous crime both by epstein and gillam
maxwell potentially others were involved
we don't know if we're going to find out
who they were or what they may have done
or what they saw
but when you look at the maxwell story
you wrote this extraordinary uh book
about robert maxwell
could you ever have imagined that this
would happen with gillane
no and i knew her first of all when she
was a very small girl when i first met
maxwell in 1973 and she was just a tiny
little girl and sweet little girl i next
saw her actually in santa pay when i was
in a party at a british property
developers party and she was pretty
sinister by then i mean
she
i don't think robert maxwell ever
imagined robert maxwell was a tyrant but
he and he bullied her and undoubtedly
she was attracted to epstein because he
was powerful and rich and she would
pervert it i mean that is in the end the
truth well it is the truth because
tonight she's been sentenced to 20 years
in prison for helping jeffrey epstein
traffic and abuse
young girls it's a despicable crime and
she is appealing and we'll see what
happens with that appeal but if she
fails the appeal she'll probably spend
the rest of her life in prison thank you
both thank you victoria thank you for
coming and appreciate it